[Musique]
le véhicule
19 nous avons fait des investissements
très sérieux parce qu'on aille plus
conscience de ce qui existait ici
vraiment c'était dans un état
indescriptible la commission a télé et
où peux vous assurer qu'il ya plus de
100 camions de redire déchets de tous
ordres qui ont été extraits de ce cycle
personnellement mon sa motion samsung
je ne peux pas continuer comme ça qu'on
va passer c'est moi laissez du sénat
c'est une bombe écologique on l'a donnée
[Musique]
qui suivent
ici voilà y'a pas mal et filet
[Musique]
ce matin sur rooney peut faire l'état
des lieux
mais avant d entreprise et j'ai comme
l'impression qu'on arrive on n'a rien on
n'en rien faire
[Musique]